hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen schön dass
ihr bei uns im Stream seid unser Thema
sind heute die Drohnenangriffe Russlands
auf die Ukraine seit Tagen treffen sie
die zivile Infrastruktur seit Tagen
treffen sie die Energieversorgung und
seit Tagen löschen Sie weiter wahllos
Menschenleben aus es ist die nächste
Eskalationsstufe in diesem Krieg und es
ist der nächste Beleg dafür Putins
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
errichtet sich gegen jeden einzelnen
Menschen in der Ukraine wir wollen
deswegen differenziert analysieren heute
diese Frage wie entscheidend sind denn
Putins Drohnen und wie kann sich die
Ukraine dagegen schützen vorher aber
noch der Blick aufs aktuelle denn Putin
selbst er hat heute Mittag in den vier
zuletzt annektierten Gebieten das
sogenannte Kriegsrecht ausgerufen sein
Militär hat damit jetzt einfach noch
mehr Macht und Kontrolle kann so etwas
zum Beispiel Ausgangssperren verhängen
und auch die Bevölkerung auffordern für
Russland in den Krieg zu ziehen
gleichzeitig hat Russland mit
großangelegten Evakuierungen in der
Region Herr Song begonnen baut Kreml
plane die ukrainische Armee der eine
großangelegte Gegenoffensive um das
Gebiet zurückzuerobern die ukrainische
Seite sie spricht von einer Zitat
propaganda-show um die Einwohner mit
falschnachrichten zu verunsichern
Putin versucht also mit diesen
Ankündigungen und auch mit den
Luftangriffen die Oberhand in dem Krieg
zurückzubekommen aber auf dem Boden das
haben wir gerade gesehen und gehört da
präsentiert sich offenbar doch noch ein
gegenteiliges Bild viele Entwicklungen
und sicher auch viele Fragen von euch
stellt die deswegen gerne ihr kennt das
direkt in die Chats wir haben das ja
alles im Blick wir sortieren das und
versuchen das dann natürlich so viel wie
möglich an unsere Gesprächspartnerinnen
und Gesprächspartner weiterzuleiten
einzuordnen direkt in die Chats oder per
Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de wie gesagt wir
versuchen das heute alles zu sortieren
und Orientierung zu geben später in der
Sendung mit Michael Karl vom German
Institut for defence and strategic
studies es ist ein Think Tank der
deutschen Bundeswehr und Michael ist da
vorne im spezialisiert auf moderne
Kriegsführung und Drohnen jetzt aber
erstmal sprechen wir mit unserem
Korrespondenten vor Ort in Kiew das ist
Dara Hassan sadi erstmal schön guten
Abend daran hier schön dass du bei uns
bist
hallo hi
Sarah auch heute wieder Drohnen und
Raketenangriffe in der gesamten Ukraine
was weißt Du darüber was ist der
aktuelle Stand und wie erlebst du es
auch vor Ort in KEF selbst
ja also man ist es jetzt leider schon
gewöhnt und heute schlugen im Norden von
Kiew wieder Luftangriffe ein es sind
über das ganze Land verteilt
Luftangriffe gewesen zum ersten Mal
jetzt auch wieder im tief im Westen der
Ukraine
in der Nähe der Karpaten also es scheint
kein wirkliches kein wirkliches System
dahinter zu sein und das Gefühl macht
sich breit dass man im Grunde überall
getroffen werden kann und ich glaube das
ist auch wirklich genauso gewollt von
der russischen Seite das lässt sich
Strategie sein könnte natürlich will man
vorwiegend auch die
Elektrizitätswerke treffen oder
Kraftwerk oder kritische Infrastruktur
damit möglichst viele Menschen in diesem
Winter große Probleme haben
thematisierst du schon die große Sorge
da kommen wir gleich noch drauf zu
sprechen aber vielleicht erstmal die
Frage an dich was weißt Du darüber wie
groß sind denn da die Schäden an der
Energieversorgung wie ist da der Zustand
ja die das ukrainische Stromnetz ist am
Rande
es sind 30 Prozent der Kraftwerke
getroffen worden der Elektrizitätswerk
hat Präsident selenski selber bekannt
gegeben das heißt das System arbeitet
auf Kante und es ist im Endeffekt auch
eine Art Wettlauf entstanden zwischen
den ukrainischen Ingenieuren die
reparieren und den russischen
Luftangriffen die zerstören und wie
dieser Weltlauf ausgeht ist im Moment
noch schwer zu sagen und wird ganz ganz
zentral von der Luftabwehr der Ukraine
abhängen vielleicht bleiben wir dann
noch mal ganz kurz du sagst sprichst es
an die Luftabwehr was muss darüber
hinaus geschehen dass die Zeit eben
ausreicht diese Reparaturarbeiten
schneller als die Angriffe durchzuführen
das hängt an den modernen
luftabwehrsystemen die jetzt hier
herkommen müssen eigentlich wenn diese
weitere Zerstörung nicht vorangehen soll
man muss darf auch nicht vergessen dass
auch mit dem großen AKW Europas größtes
AKW in saporischer ein ganz großes
Potenzial für das ukrainische Stromnetz
schon lange nicht mehr existiert damals
hatte man ja noch vor wenigen Wochen die
Hoffnung dass die Ukraine Strom in den
nach Europa exportieren könnte und jetzt
zählt eigentlich jeder Megawattstunde
putin will ja mit diesen Angriffen haben
wir gerade rausgearbeitet zum einen
zivile Infrastruktur treffen die
Energieversorgung treffen und erlöscht
damit wahllos weiter Menschenleben aus
was er auch abzielt ist natürlich die
Moral der ukrainischen Bevölkerung zu
brechen was erlebst du da vor Ort wie
groß ist die Sorge oder schafft er das
überhaupt nicht bei dieser ukrainischen
Bevölkerung diese zu brechen
also ich würde jetzt ungern pauschal für
alle Ukrainer sprechen weil ich
natürlich zwangsläufig nicht alle
getroffen und gesprochen habe aber ich
kann vielleicht mal schildern wie das so
ist wir waren bei Dreharbeiten und dann
war Luftalarm und es war am Tag wo die
ihre also der iranische Drohne schon
eingeschlagen ist und wir sind in die
nächste Tiefgarage gelaufen da hat sich
so ein Gefühl von seiner
Schicksalsgemeinschaft breit es gibt die
jüngeren Leute die standen eher in der
Einfahrt und haben dort noch
Handyempfang gehabt dann tief in der
Garage drin wo es kein Empfang gibt
saßen
ältere Menschen die prophylaktisch schon
mit dem Kissen ausgehen falls Sie länger
sitzen müssen während eines luftalarms
dann gab es besorgte Eltern und das
schmerzende wirklich dieser Anblick die
ihre Kleinkinder auf dem Arm haben und
sich fragen warum müssen die sowas
erleben auch wenn Sie natürlich in
diesem Moment in Sicherheit waren
Programmierer André hieß der hat mir
erzählt das ist er ist immer wieder
erstaunt über sein eigenes menschliches
Gehirn weil er war Anwohner bei diesem
Anschlag und er hat einfach alles
gespürt die Angst gehabt und jetzt sitzt
er schon wieder hier eine halbe Stunde
später und überlegt sich was er nach
Ende des luftalarms wieder machen wird
wie sein Alltag fortgeht und das ist
glaube ich die Situation in der die
Bandbreite sage ich mal
prinzipiell kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass der gewünschte Effekt
bei der Mehrheit der Ukraine Eintritt
die sagen ich bin lieber bereit
irgendeine Art von diktatfrieden zu
akzeptieren es hauptsache es hört auf
mit dem Beschuss im Gegenteil und wenn
man in die Geschichte blickt
[Musik]
hat ja auch Deutschland die
massenbombardierung erlebt es hat ja
auch nicht dazu geführt dass während des
Dritten Reichs gegen Ende in Dresden auf
einmal weniger Nazis da waren sie haben
ja auch bis zum Ende zu dem Regime
gehalten oder prinzipiell durchgehalten
ich glaube nicht an die Demoralisierung
durch Schrecken da gibt es zu viele
beides rückt die Menschen auch sehr sehr
stark zusammen und fördert natürlich
auch sehr viel Hass
du beschreibst die Spannweite du
beschreibst aber auch
die Perspektive sich immer wieder
Hoffnung zu machen in der Bevölkerung in
der ukrainischen trotz dieser Angriffe
wie schaffen Sie das
also es ist wirklich der Humor dieser
Menschen der sie zum Lachen bringt auf
einmal löst sich alles und der ist
wirklich überall zu finden und das ist
was ganz besonderes und das gibt ihnen
Hoffnung das gibt ihnen Mut es ist schon
das ist schon ihrer aus welche in
welchen Situationen dort ganz trockene
Sprüche kommen Witze gemacht werden und
einen
ukrainisches Sprichwort sagt auch ich
lache um nicht weinen zu müssen und sie
entscheiden sich dann fürs lachen
du oder wir haben es auch vorhin schon
gehört Putin hat heute das Kriegsrecht
in den vier annektierten Gebieten
verhängt da kommt eine Frage rein an
Dich von einem User bei Youtube er fragt
wie war es Putin möglich dieses
Kriegsrecht zu verhängen und zweite
Frage hänge ich drin hinten dran wie hat
sozusagen die Ukraine jetzt darauf
reagiert
näher möglich ist
vieles er kann sich ja hinstellen und es
behaupten im Moment
auch wenn es von der von weiten Teil der
Weltgemeinschaft nicht anerkannt wird
hat er natürlich bei den russisch
besetzten Gebieten der Ukraine einfach
das faktische
durchgriffsmöglichkeit die er hat das
Militär da in dem Gebieten und die
setzen dann diese Anweisungen um
die zweite Frage die Reaktion der
Ukraine die war relativ klar der
präsidentenberater podalliak hat gesagt
das sind
pseudo-lekitimierungen von Plündereien
und die Ukraine wird unbeirrt die
Befreiung der besetzten Gebiete
fortsetzen also da sind sie ganz klar
und
lassen sich davon überhaupt nicht
beeindrucken es ist natürlich so dass
das Kriegsrecht wie schon angesprochen
habe dann durchaus umgesetzt wird in den
russisch besetzten Gebieten und ein
Passus wird vor für die Pro ukrainischen
Menschen in den russisch besetzten
Gebieten zum kann zum Problem werden
nämlich
das Kriegsrecht erlaubt auch das
Einziehen von Menschen für die
territoriale Verteidigung wenn das
geschieht dann könnten pro ukrainische
Menschen in den Gebieten an der Seite
der Russen für Russland gegen die
ukrainische Armee kämpfen und von der
will sie ja wollen diese Menschen
befreit werden also das ist glaube ich
eine Situation die dort jetzt viele
Menschen beschäftigt
darüber sprechen heute über die
Drohnenangriffe aus den vergangenen
Tagen da kommt noch eine weitere
user-frage rein vom Tom Frank er fragte
ich direkt vielleicht kannst du uns da
die Eindrücke dann einfach aus Kiew aus
der Ukraine geben was machen die
Ukrainer in Kiew und anderswo konkret
gegen die Drohnen gibt es eine Taktik
aus der Bevölkerung heraus versucht die
Polizei die Dinge abzuschießen was
erlebst du da
heute Abend da wird alles versucht jede
Drohne bringt den Tod auf die für die
Menschen hier also es gab die Ukraine
wirft alles in die Waagschale was hier
an militärischer Luftabwehr hat es gibt
Situationen diese diese die
sind eher verzweifelt Polizisten die
eine langsam fliegende Drohne sehen
eröffnen das Feuer in der Hoffnung ein
Glückstreffer zu setzen gehen aber
natürlich gleichzeitig das Risiko von
Querschlägern ein oder dass die Kugeln
die Drohne verfehlt verfehlen die fallen
ja auch irgendwo wieder runter es gibt
Initiativen von technisch versierten
Ingenieuren die versuchen
technischer
[Musik]
Ersatzteile für die Luftabwehr
nachzubauen das ist closed to Sky ist
das was uns die Menschen schon im März
zugerufen haben voller Verzweiflung und
der Himmel ist immer noch nicht
geschlossen
daran Hassan sah die live aus Kiew mit
Eindrücken Schilderungen und Erklärungen
vielen Dank dafür heute hier bei ZDF
heute live
unsere Frage ist heute wie entscheidend
ist der Einsatz von den Drohnen von den
iranischen Drohnen im russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine und was
kann die ukrainische Armee
entgegensetzen bevor wir darüber jetzt
gleich ausführlich mit Michael Karl
sprechen zeigen uns Pablo silalahi und
Tabea Layer aber erst einmal was da
gerade für Drohnen im Einsatz sind und
wer sie an Russland geliefert hat
das Herz von Kiew unter Feuer seit gut
zehn Tagen ist der Krieg zurück in der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt und damit tot
Leid Zerstörung
verursacht mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit
durch sie Drohnen vom Typ Shahid 136
hergestellt im Iran eine sogenannte
kamikarzitrone mit einer Spannweite von
gerade mal 2,5 Metern sehr klein es sind
sogenannte lauernde Waffen sie werden
mit einer Rakete gestartet Kreisen
mittels Propellerantrieb lauernd bevor
sie auf ihr Ziel stürzen kaum mehr
steuerbar und ungenau an Bord ein
Sprengsatz der beim Einschlag detoniert
mit der doppelten bis dreifachen
Sprengkraft eines herkömmlichen
artilleriegeschosses
vom Radar sind sie schwer zu erfassen
wegen ihrer geringen Flughöhe und
deshalb schwer abzufangen Russland
bestreitet iranische Drohnen zu benutzen
behauptet sie unter dem Namen gerannt 2
selbst gebaut zu haben doch Recherchen
der Washington Post zufolge plant der
Iran nicht nur weitere head 136 Drohnen
an Moskau zu liefern sondern noch viel
schlagkräftigere unter ihnen auch eine
Drohne die eine Reichweite von bis zu
2000 Kilometern haben soll fast das
Dreifache
parallel dazu gab es heute auch noch die
Meldung von der New York Times die sich
auf Informationen vom Geheimdienst
berufen dass der Iran Ausbilder auf die
Krim schicken will um die russischen
Piloten eben für den Einsatz mit den
Drohnen weiter zu schulen die EU die hat
darauf auch heute reagiert und weitere
Sanktionen beschlossen gegen Personen
und Organisationen die für den Bau und
die Lieferung dieser Drohnen an Russland
zuständig sind
damit jetzt guten Abend an Michael kahl
wir analysieren weiter vom German
Institut vor defence and the tasic
studies es ist eine Denkfabrik der
Bundeswehr danke Herr Karl dass sie ihre
Expertise heute mit uns teilen
ja vielen Dank auch an sie
unsere Frage ist heute wie entscheidend
sind diese Drohnen für den weiteren
Kriegsverlauf und was kann die Ukraine
dagegen tun Ukrainisch Präsident
silenski er schätzt das so ein
der russische Hilferuf an den Iran ist
die Anerkennung des militärischen und
politischen Bankrotts durch den kremme
russland hat jahrzehntelang Milliarden
Dollar in seinen militärisch
industriellen Komplex gesteckt doch
schließlich muss es auf ziemlich
einfache Drohnen und Raketen aus
teheransetzen
strategisch wird es ihnen ohnehin nicht
helfen es zeigt der Welt nur dass
Russland auf dem Weg zur Niederlage ist
und versucht noch jemand anderen als
terror-komplizen mit hineinzuziehen
Herr Karl soweit Präsident selenski wie
sehen Sie das
ja das sind sehr entscheidende Worte
gewesen vom ukrainischen Präsidenten und
nach unserer Bewertung die auch in die
Richtung geht
wo wir die Einschätzung haben Leute und
amonition also kamikazetronen jetzt
gegen die Zivilbevölkerung einzusetzen
das kommt natürlich nicht von ungefähr
wir haben Russlands Verluste seit dem 24
Februar diesen Jahres verfolgt und
kommen also bei
übereinander legen der Resultate und der
verlustquoten auch dazu nur noch 30%
raketenmunition ich meine
raketenmunition die durch Werfer Systeme
an den Frontlinien verschossen wurden
sind mehr als
1.200 Drohnen der alten russischen Art
Bauweise sind abgeschossen worden
ungefähr 1200 wir haben
wir haben hohe Verluste bei Artillerie
und mehrfachwerfer
Geschützen der russischen Streitkräfte
an die 2000 die verloren bereits
verloren gegangen sind von menschliche
Verlusten rede ich jetzt noch gar nicht
also wer jetzt meint einen drohnenkrieg
gewinnen zu können auf der Basis eines
Landes wie die Ukraine der liegt
vollkommen falsch und das ist der blanke
Terror der hier durchgeführt wird der
also in Kiel von den anderen Großstädten
in der Ukraine jetzt gerade in die
Zivilbevölkerung durchmachen muss
sie werden
auch da teile ich die Meinung ihrer
Kollegin die aus Kiew berichtet hat sie
werden
den Willen des ukrainischen Volkes nicht
brechen dadurch im Gegenteil also auch
so wie unsere Front Berichte wie die
Berichte auch waren über das Militär
während des gesamten Krieges seit
Februar bis dato wann immer genauer
immer noch ein lächelndes da und der
Erfolg gibt ihnen recht denn was am
Boden gerade passiert oder bereits seit
einigen Wochen passiert ist das ist
nicht im Sinne der russischen
Streitkräfte und jetzt muss mit allen
Mitteln versucht werden ein Erfolg muss
her Putin steht unter dem Zwang ein
Erfolg muss her und das versucht man nun
mit Drohnen
tja
zu verrichten
ja wichtig dass Sie das so einschätzen
dass hier der blanke Terror herrscht und
wichtig dass sie auch noch mal das so
einschätzen dass das Lächeln in der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung weiterhin da
ist deswegen schließt sich die
user-frage von Caterpillar da vielleicht
an was glauben sie dann können diese
Drohnen die gegen Offensive der Ukraine
verlangsamt oder gar stoppen dann
wahrscheinlich nicht ihre Einschätzung
nach oder
nein nein
da gehe ich überhaupt nicht fern aus
also der Krieg wird auch anders geführt
klar Drohnen also ich kenne jetzt
verschiedene Typen dieser Kamikaze
Drohnen sie können einen Effekt hierher
holen aber so clever wie du keiner sind
wie sie sich bereits während des
gesamten Krieges auch immer wieder auf
Situationen eingestellt haben denken Sie
mal dran die Schwachstelle des T-72
Bravo 3 rausgefunden zu haben die
wussten genau wo sie hinschießen mussten
mit Panzerabwehrwaffen und die Ukrainer
werden mit Hilfe des Westens wenn sie
einen Weg finden diese Drohnen auch
entsprechend also die Drohnenangriffe zu
verringern wenn ich sogar einzustellen
in großen Bereich
genau was da auch helfen kann vom Westen
in Sachen Flugabwehrsysteme darüber
sprechen wir gleich vorher noch eine
Frage per Mail von Heiko Schlegel das
geht so ein bisschen jetzt dass man
diese Angriffe ein bisschen besser
versteht technisch für diese Drohnen
funktionieren vielleicht können sie uns
da Aufklärung geben er fragt Heiko
Schlegel werden die Drohnen
ferngesteuert haben sie irgendwie eine
Kamera die den Piloten bei der Steuerung
Orientierung gibt wird das Ziel vor
Abschlus programmiert wie funktioniert
das
ja das sind quasi alle Möglichkeiten
oder mehrere Möglichkeiten schon genannt
wurden selbstverständlich diese Drohne
also sie können die programmieren
das heißt der drohnenpilot kann also
abends schon festlegen er kriegt er bei
der Befehlsausgabe gesagt die Drohne
soll dauern da und dein Team hier zum
Beispiel runterkommen da kann er das für
das eingestellt über das entsprechende
sehende Auge also die Kamera dieses
Waffensystems fliegt die Drohne dann
auch sie kann über dem Ziel verharren
und kann dann bei entsprechender oder
dem entsprechenden Momentum jetzt soll
sie eingesetzt werden kann sie auf das
Ziel abgesteuert werden allerdings
ist bei der Erläuterung emmanischen oder
bei den kamikazedonen gerade auch dieses
Typs ist es ein großer seine
flächenwaffe eher also die genaue
Präzision ist schwierig
aber sie kommt in dem in etwa in dem
Raum runter so wenn man jetzt die
Angriffe nimmt der Drohnen auf auf
Stadtviertel wo Menschen leben dann sind
Sie immer im Ziel das heißt sie haben
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr hoch
dass sie nicht nur Schaden anrichtet
sondern auch Menschen tötet und deswegen
ist sie natürlich sehr effektvoll was
das ganze noch
ja
sehr kritisch auch noch macht das Ganze
dass diese Drohnen auch eins zwei drei
Stunden über dem Ziel als dann bleiben
können sie können sich also tatsächlich
dann eine ein besonderes Ziel noch
aussuchen was durch den
drohnenpiloten der weit weg sitzt
entsprechend dann auslösen kann das ist
das perfide bei dieser Waffe
das heißt wie genau könnte man die Frage
wie zielgenau sie sind dann einschätzen
sie sagen sie sind effektvoll sie
treffen in dem Rahmen ein aber die
genaue hundertprozentige Präzision haben
sie dann eigentlich nicht
also ich denke mal das so wie ich diese
diesen also diesen diesen throntyp
selber ich kenne ihn aber ich könnte das
jetzt nur über die ukrainische Drohne
sagen also die die türkische bayrakter
TW2 die sehr präzise ist also da kommt
es wiederum drauf an was für ein
thronentyp das ist der eingesetzt wird
aber von der Scharbe oder
Irland 2 wie die Russen sie nennen
kann ich zumindest sagen dass sie eine
Zielgenauigkeit hat aber wie ganz genau
das kann ich Ihnen noch nicht sagen sie
sprechen gerade die türkische Drohne die
die Ukraine verwendet beirata tb2 an
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam rausschauen
denn auch die Ukraine sie verwendet seit
Beginn des Kriegs Drohnen Anfang März
2022 da hat sie also keine Armee
russische Panzerkolonnen vor Kiew eben
mit Drohnen angegriffen sie nutzt eben
die türkische Drohne beiracter tb2 und
dabei sollen laut ukrainischen Angaben
bereits dutzende russische Panzer
Schiffe und Konvois zerstört worden sein
Herr Karl Frage an Sie was ist konkret
der Unterschied zwischen diesen beiden
drohtypen
also die bayraxathrone aus der Türkei
hat erstmal schon mal
langwierigere oder langwierigere
Erfahrungen aus zum Beispiel aus dem
bergkarabachkrieg also aserbaidschan hat
diese Drohne genutzt
sie ist
perfektioniert also sie ist sehr nach
westlichen Modellen auch nach kreiert
wurden sie ist ausgestattet mit also im
Gegensatz zu einer leutering oder
Kamikaze Drohne kann sie auch mit
Raketen also ähnlich der Griffin oder
Hellfire Rakete die wir von den
Amerikanern kennen ausgestattet werden
das heißt sie bleibt in der Luft stehen
und kann entsprechend präzise feuern
also das Feuerleitsystem und die
Visiereinrichtung mit der Optik in
Kombination bei der beitragter sie ist
zielgenauer
und werden
entsprechenden Effekt
ich wollte nicht unterbrechen werden sie
aktuell auch noch eingesetzt wissen sie
da was drüber
die beiratronen
sie werden eingesetzt alles klar bleibt
noch die Frage die auch im Chat
auftaucht noch mal zurück zu den Drohne
die gerade die russische Armee einsetzt
von wo aus werden sie gestartet gibt es
darüber Informationen
ja das ist das ist natürlich
entsprechend da müsste man sich jetzt
angucken wo liegen die russischen
Verbände also Verbände meine ich jetzt
Einheiten oder oder Verbände
Großverbände und dort sind natürlich
auch entsprechend die diese Drohnen mit
angehangen und aufgehangen das heißt
also der Kommandeur eines Bataillons als
Beispiel bekommt den Befehl seine Thron
entsprechend einzusetzen oder
entsprechend so so viel Truhen
zu programmieren und zu starten und dann
auch entsprechend einzusetzen das heißt
diese Drohnen sind Bestandteil der
russischen Streitkräfte aber interessant
ist jetzt um noch mal die
Unterschiedlichkeit auch zu nehmen
wenn die Ukrainer die bei ragta tb2
Drohne gegen Kampfverbände einsetzt was
ja klar das Mittel auch ist eigentlich
wenn die russischen drohen war sie auf
die Zivilbevölkerung abgefeuert das ist
der kleine Unterschied das heißt der der
russische Kommandeur der das befiehlt
befiehlt gleichzeitig auch den Angriff
auf die Zivilbevölkerung der Ukraine
ja und genau diese Angriffe das wissen
wir sie finden mittlerweile täglich
statt wir können uns mal gemeinsam die
ukrainische luftalarm-karte anschauen da
sehen wir das normalerweise ist sie so
nicht eingefärbt sie ist fast täglich
komplett rot eingefärbt wechselt
dazwischen hier sind die überwiegenden
jetzt leicht rot eingefärbt manchmal
sieht es aber genauso aus wie hier am
Rande also komplett rot also tägliche
Angriffe die Frage die sich dann
natürlich stellt Herr Karl wie viele
dieser Drohnen hat Putin eigentlich zur
Verfügung wenn jetzt auch der Iran und
die iranische Regierung da weitere
liefert
also da muss ich auf die Zahlen jetzt
auch unsere Alliierten zugreifen und die
schwanken also ich habe
einen Bereich von 600 drohen die die
russischen Streitkräfte haben bis 2400
dieser thronen und da gibt es auch noch
mal Unterschiedlichkeiten also es gibt
da qualitative und preisliche
Unterschiede
man hat das ja vorhin sehr gut im
Bericht auch gesagt eine zwei Meter
fünfzig ungefähr ist die Spannweite die
Russen behaupten etwas von einer Lizenz
ja es ist trotzdem die chapet Drohne die
136 und die gibt es in der Preislage von
20.000 Dollar bis 10.000 Dollar gut dann
hat natürlich die 10.000 Dollar Drohne
nicht die Qualität der teureren Drohne
aber die genaue Anzahl das ist schwer zu
erfassen im Moment
ja trotzdem danke dass wir uns die Range
geschildert haben gehen wir mal auf den
Punkt wie kann man sich denn gegen diese
Drohnen jetzt wehren die
Flugabwehrsysteme die die Ukraine
aktuell zur Verfügung hat sie haben
große Schwierigkeiten sie starten
teilweise viel zu spät ihre
Abwehrmechanismen egal was genau macht
es denn so schwierig diese Drohnen
abzuwehren
ja wir müssen jetzt erstmal von
traditioneller Flugabwehr ausgehen also
wir reden jetzt von Waffensystemen die
bereits in der sowjetischen Armee also
sprich vor 1990 verwendet worden ist
sogenannte zsu-systeme die ist dann in
Rohr Varianten von zsu2 bis ZSO 4 gab ja
also klassisch mit mit einer 20 und bis
30 mm Spreng brandmunition versucht
Flugziele zu treffen
das ist schwer deswegen diese Drohne ich
habe vorhin gesagt 2,50 m Spannweite das
ist nicht besonders groß und wenn sie
dann noch nehmen diese Drohne fliegt
sehr niedrig was im Bericht ja auch
gesagt worden ist hier muss jetzt zu
anderen Mitteln gegriffen werden also
zum Beispiel Jammer Systeme das heißt
Störsender die den Kontakt zwischen dem
drohnenpiloten zur Drohne stören und die
Flugfähigkeit soweit einschränken dass
sie einfach runterfällt ja
das kann auch jetzt könnte man ja sagen
der hat ja Sprengstoff an Bord ja aber
das Risiko ist gering wenn der Kontakt
unterbrochen ist zwischen Piloten drohen
Piloten und Drohne selber und man kann
sie mit einem Störsender zum
runterfallen bringen dann ist es
normalerweise eine große Chance da dass
sie einfach wirkungslos ist das nächste
ist was gemacht wird ist ich habe das
vorhin gehört im Bericht mit den
Schüssen aus Pistolen oder allem was man
greifbar hat das ist natürlich
abhängig von der jeweiligen Situation
also wenn man auf freiem Felde steht
diese Drohne ist sehr laut das habe ich
vergessen noch zu sagen sie hat dann so
ungefähr die die Lärm von dem Motorsäge
oder von dem von dem Motorroller also
wenn die anfliegt also das hört man dann
schon ja und wer dann natürlich in der
Stadt steht und feuert dass das
vollkommen richtig da ist die Gefahr
sehr groß dass man dass man vielleicht
andere trifft aber es geht hier um den
Mittel zum das Mittel zum Zweck also um
die Drohne abzufeuern klar die
Schwierigkeit könnte dann dabei liegen
weil sie halt getroffen wird ist der
Kontakt ja zum drohnenpiloten noch da
könnte sie immer noch explodieren und
das ist natürlich dann eine
Schwierigkeit also es müssen Systeme her
wie Störsender sogenannte Jammer
Fang drohen so was gibt es auch
mittlerweile
die also Drohnen auch einfangen können
und wie gesagt die Lamm Langsamkeit und
der Lärm dieser Drohne das ist
auszunutzen aber ich bin mir da auch
hundertprozentig sicher a da wird
bereits daran gearbeitet um das
einzuschränken oder zu minimieren und B
auch dass es entsprechend Systeme geben
wird nochmal ganz kurz zu den
amerikanischen gemmern da kommt auch
eine Anschlussfrage von unserem User Rom
was bringen die konkret gegen diese
drohen vielleicht können Sie das einmal
noch mal erklären
also durch den Störsender das sind
Erfahrungen die wir aus Afghanistan zum
Beispiel auch haben also sprich wir
unterbrechen die Verbindung eines
Attentäters vom Handy zum Sprengsatz
also dem Iod der irgendwo vergraben war
und ungefähr nach demselben Prinzip geht
das auch die Drohne ist verbunden mit
einem Sender mit dem Piloten also im
drohnenpiloten der irgendwo in seinem
russischen Verband sitzt und dieser
Drohne quasi führt und über das Tablet
auch sieht wo die Drohne hinfliegt wird
diese Verbindung gestört wird diese
Verbindung unterbrochen ist sie
Drohne hilflos dann fällt sie runter
dann kann der Pilot keinen Einfluss mehr
auf die Drohne selbst nehmen so ist das
gemeint und den zweiten Aspekt sie haben
einmal die Funkstörung angesprochen den
zweiten Aspekt die weitere Entwicklung
neuer Abwehrsysteme die Ukraine sie hat
sich auch dazu bereits geäußert und
gesagt dass das israelische iron Dome
Abwehrsystem ein System wäre das
effektiv helfen würde Israel hat die
Lieferung aber bislang verneint es will
stattdessen jetzt bei der Errichtung
eines Frühwarnsystems helfen das hört
man heute zu dieser politischen Debatte
kommen wir gleich bleiben wir erstmal
beim System was genau könnte denn iron
Dawn bewirken
ist natürlich eine eine ganz
hervorragende präzise
flugabwehrwaffe die Israel quasi
verwendet man muss sich das vorstellen
dass das ähnlich ist eine Glocke die
sich über das Land legt dafür brauchen
sie entsprechende command and control
Systeme das heißt die Koordinierung und
das Besondere bei Iron Dome ist dass ihr
nicht nur auf Drohnen reagieren also
Abwehrmaßnahmen gegen anfliegende
Drohnen
ergreift sondern auch gegen missalz also
gegen Raketen gegen Artilleriegeschosse
gegen Mörsergranaten also jegliche Art
von Werfer bzw
Artilleriemunition oder sogar
raketenmunition die eingesetzt wird also
nur mal so paar Zahlen als die Israelis
das erstmalig einsetzen sind von acht
Raketen die einflogen auf israelisches
Territorium auch alle acht abgeschossen
wurden
jetzt ist natürlich so es vom Gegner
schnell erkannt worden je mehr ich
einsetze desto mehr wird natürlich das
System auch gefordert so aber trotzdem
mit ganz hoher Anzahl an geschossen die
einflogen wurden immer noch über 50
Prozent abgeschossen so und das ist
jetzt noch weiter noch weiter verbessert
worden das System
was meine letzte Information heute
Morgen war das Israel genau ähnlich wie
sie auch sagten bereit sind ein
frühwaren aber auch ein älteres
Abwehrsystem an die Ukraine zu liefern
aber ich denke schlussendlich hat das
natürlich politische Gründe auch welche
sind das wenn ich da vielleicht ganz
kurz einhaken darf welche welche sehen
sie da natürlich natürlich ja also ich
sehe zum einen es geht um die um man
würde ja quasi ein System was
lebenswichtig ist für den Staat Israel
würde man ja quasi preisgeben und das
ist nicht so ganz einfach aber ich wie
gesagt ich vermute da jetzt mitunter
auch also das beste nicht aber eher dann
Hilfe jawohl Hilfe soll geleistet werden
aber mit einem älteren System und einem
hilfreichen Frühwarnsystem
Hilfe ist ein gutes Stichwort kommen wir
zum Thema Hilfe vielleicht auch aus
Deutschland User last chance the sea 42
fragt welche Systeme zu drohen Abwehr
sind seitens der Bundeswehr geplant
naja da ist ja bekannt dass das also kam
zumindest in den Medien wo das schon
dargestellt die Iris die SLM soll
geschickt werden also ein System auch
der
Frühwarnung aber auch ein ein
jammersystem also was mit Störsender auf
störsenderbasis mitunter arbeitet
da sind auch ist auch angekündigt worden
acht weitere Systeme zu schicken um die
Ukraine damit zu unterstützen
gibt es darüber hinaus es war heute auch
zu lesen dass noch weitere Systeme neben
dem von Ihnen angesprochenen Iris tssm
System gibt es darüber hinaus noch
weitere Systeme die vorbereitet werden
und jetzt weitergeschickt werden
also ich weiß nur dass es derzeit
darüber Gespräche gibt aber was ist
genau ist kann ich Ihnen noch nicht
sagen alles klar dann blicken wir neben
der Eskalationsstufe der Drohnenangriffe
auf eine weitere Eskalationsstufe die
Putin
angekündigt hat sich immer weiter offen
lässt die Einbeziehung von Belarus
Moskau und Minsk sie haben jetzt gerade
auch eine Stationierung einer
gemeinsamen Zitat amigruppierung an der
ukrainischen Grenze vereinbart die
Gruppe soll bis zu 9000 Mann stark sein
170 Panzer bis zu 100 schwere
artilleriesysteme verfügen und die Angst
beziehungsweise die Aussage vom
ukrainischen präsidentenberater ist dass
da womöglich bis Jahresende eine neue
Offensive auf Kiew möglich sei er
schätzt die Wahrscheinlichkeit bei 50 50
das Zitat sie genau mitten im Winter
kommen wie groß schätzen Sie diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit ein
ja da gibt es das für und wieder ne also
wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt
militärisch beurteile eine Stärke von
9.000 Mann mit 170 Panzern und 100
schwere artilleriesysteme
ja das ist eine Brigade ungefähr mit mit
einer sehr guten Bewaffnung also für die
Zuhörer mal also Brigade ist der
kleinste selbstständige Großverband
und das ist natürlich schon ein
Potenzial aber wir wissen auch wie die
Erfahrungen sind der ukrainische
Streitkräfte mit dem Angriff auf Kiew
der im Februar März erfolgte und wie es
dann ausgegangen ist
richtig ist dass Belarus gerade
geostrategisch sehr sehr wichtig ist für
Russland und es ist eigentlich auch für
Lukaschenko und Minsk die
Überlebensfähigkeit nämlich diese diese
unheilige Allianz mit Moskau und
Russland weiterzuhalten es ist quasi der
geostrategische Vorsprung also ich
meinte jetzt
territoriale Vorsprung den Russland
braucht um auch zu NATO entsprechend
Verbindung zu haben aber auch um seine
Fläche zu Ukraine oder gemeinsame Grenze
zu Kreide zu erweitern
inwieweit aber die russischen Kräfte in
der Lage sind denken Sie daran im
Februar aber auch die Offensive der
russischen Streit ja und da waren alle
noch frisch mit 150.000 und das ist
kläglich gescheitert ja also wer die
russischen Militär Doktrinen seit frunse
also 1920 bis dato gelesen hat wir haben
die auch bewertet sind ganz ganz viele
Dinge überhaupt nicht eingetreten es ist
überhaupt nichts passiert so und jetzt
kommt es auch dran Motivation und
gefechtswert könnt ihr das überhaupt
noch ja also hat man überhaupt diese
diesen Willen noch da einen Erfolg zu
erzielen mit blanken Drohungen gegen die
Armen Soldaten gut dass jetzt eine
Bewertung gegen den normalen Soldaten
ist es damit nicht getan
ja der thematisieren sie die bisherige
generelle Entwicklung dieses russischen
angriffskriegs gegen die Ukraine an am
Anfang die ja gescheiterte schnell
Invasion aber Putin das haben wir jetzt
auch herausgefunden er würde sich diese
Niederlage oder dieses Scheitern ja auch
nie eingestehen er greift immer weiter
zu den nächsten Eskalationsstufen sie
haben diese Drohnenangriffe auch als Akt
des Terrors heute ganz klar benannt
vielleicht als Abschlussfrage ihr Blick
wenn Sie das so einordnen die Situation
am Boden auch die Eskalationsstufe mit
Belarus vielleicht doch nicht so eine
starke Gruppe wie blicken sie auf den
weiteren Verlauf dieses Krieges a von
der zeitlichen Dimension und B auch vom
Erfolg der Ukraine vielleicht
also für mich stellt das ganze so da
dass die Russen eine Pause brauchen gut
die braucht die Ukraine auch aber der
Erfolg gibt den Ukraine
die russland hat viel zu viele weitere
und noch tiefgehendere Probleme die
reingehen bis in die russische
Gesellschaft hin ja man hat also erkannt
Oppositionen Demonstrationen der Begriff
Krieg darf nicht verwendet werden hier
wird immer nur von speziell
Militäroperationen das glaubt
mittlerweile kein Mensch mehr es sei
denn sie wurden ganz weit weg wo sie
keinerlei empfangen mehr von Internet
oder sonstigen haben die Kontrolle ist
er hat für zwei Kriege im Moment Putin
führt zwei Kriege und er ist zum Erfolg
verdammt er braucht eine Pause einen
Erfolg
und eine Pause um sich neu zu
koordinieren und ich glaube diese Pause
wird er nicht mehr bekommen so nach
unserer Bewertung diese Pause würde
nicht mehr bekommen sagt Michael kahl
vom German Institute for defence and
strategic statists in Hamburg vielen
Dank für Ihre ausführlichen Erläuterung
für ihre Detailkenntnisse und auch für
ihre Zeit hier bei ZDF heute live liebe
Grüße nach Hamburg
sehr gerne sehr gerne vielen herzlichen
Dank auch
ich bedanke mich auch sehr herzlich bei
euch wieder fürs zuschauen hier bei uns
im Stream für eure Fragen für eure
Beteiligung dass ihr Teil der Sendung
gewesen seid wir hoffen dass wir euch
Orientierung über die aktuellen
Entwicklung zwischen dem im russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine bieten
konnten auch eine Ausblick zeigen
konnten wir werden das Thema natürlich
weiter verfolgen hier bei ZDF heute live
und ihr kennt das auch darüber weiter
berichten bis dahin macht's gut noch
einen schönen Abend und tschüss